veamos si podemos factorizar 36 a 8ª más
2 b a la 6 fomentando el vídeo anterior
e intentándolo por ti mismo así que
veamos si podemos expresar esto como la
diferencia de cuadrados utilizando
números imaginarios así que puedes
reescribir
36 a la 8 como 6 al cuadrado a la 8 es
igual que a la cuarta al cuadrado y de
hecho déjame reescribir lo mejor de esta
forma esto es 6 por hada cuarta al
cuadrado lo cual es nuestro primer
término de por aquí y luego vamos con el
segundo término lo podemos reescribir
como como más reescribimos esto como más
raíz de 2 x b kubica al cuadrado y ahora
nosotros queremos reescribir esto como
la diferencia de cuadrados y
escribiéndolo de esa forma déjame
entonces cambiar este más de aquí
lo voy a limpiar y puedo describirlo
como restando restando esto y
multiplicando por un menos uno y como
sabemos este menos uno de aquí es lo
mismo que cuadrada así que podemos
reescribirlo de una vez todas estas
cosas como seis a cuarta al cuadrado
y luego tenemos este menos por aquí y
esto de acá sería lo mismo esto de aquí
es y cuadrada que es menos 1 y podemos
escribir lo como y por raíz de 2 por b
cúbica y todo esto al cuadrado pues si
cuadrada es igual a menos 1 luego es por
esta red de dos y luego es por b cúbica
que aquí simplemente lo que hace b
kubica al elevarlo al cuadrado es
multiplicar los exponentes y ahora
expresando todo esto como diferencia de
cuadrados estamos listos para factorizar
y esto va a ser igual a seis a cuarta
menos menos este segundo término
entonces sería menos y por raíz de 2 por
b cúbica por y déjame este espacio de
por aquí entonces esto va a ser x
6a cuarta más 6a cuarta más todo esto de
aquí todo este término de aquí que sería
y raíz de 2 b kubica y lo hemos hecho
esta es nuestra factorización como
diferencias